sometimes on sampling in networks with
the motivation from the the studies of
hidden human populations so for example
subgroups of people at high risk for HIV
AIDS so like commercial sex workers the
clients of commercial sex workers
injecting drug users and so on so so
people hard to sample and so the only
practical way it for most these
populations people have found to sample
them is through following social links
maybe maybe starting with some smaller
expensively done proper probability
survey but extent but they'll find many
more of them if they if they if the
field people can can talk to people and
find out who else they know and there's
there's a various ways of doing it and
either finding those people having the
researchers find those people themselves
or or using coupons or something to have
the people you know find bring in reap
recruit their contacts that way and so
much of the problem I work on was taking
samples like that and figure out how do
we do make inference about the larger
network so we imagine there's um we can
see but some pop population of people
that is connected in one way or another
we're interested in this whole
population and we we go in and we sample
somebody at random Sayer by some other
means or sample some group like that and
then follow a link and here we've got
more than one link to follow maybe we'll
choose one by chance or maybe we'll you
know maybe we'll through some subset of
them so it's very flexible lots of
different plans and what what what most
of these link
tracing designs have in common if we're
looking for a high risk behavior you
know such as I'm injecting injecting
drug use or commercial sex involvement
or something will will tend to find
people with higher probability who are
more likely to I mean people with the
high risk behavior or we're more likely
to find them they're more likely to have
these risk related links and so it's
it's that kind of problem that we try to
unravel with the inference so so that's
just inference that's one thing we can
do with sampling designs in a setting
like this and I'll talk about the
broader picture today so so for the
inference problem itself yet you know
for a long time people would just say
well these are our data and the percent
of people in our study who inject drugs
say is you know 47 there is a
sixty-seven percent or something but the
real percent in the population might be
less than that and so so the methods of
entrance we've been most successful with
their I'd say first of all there's the
strictly design based inference where we
use we don't assume any stochastic graph
model any kind of model about the
population and the density of links or
what model we just use the probability
like if I selected this person at random
then and went to this version well
there's only one place I could go but
but here you know if they were here
let's say if there's you know there's a
certain probability given that I met
this person I see some links there are
certain probabilities of following gives
links and conditionally we can figure
out all those probabilities even though
we can't figure out the unconditional
probability that someone like this is in
the sample so we can't use the classical
unequal probability sampling estimators
that divided by those probabilities but
but so now we've got an unbiased
estimate say by using the conditional
probabilities but that depends on order
it's not your best estimate and we
improve those using the Blackwell method
you know bite by taking the you know our
simple unbiased estimator might be just
this value of the randomly selected node
but we could have selected this person
first and followed in another direction
so the route Blackwell estimate leads us
to to average different estimates over
different sample paths each sample path
having a different probability and
there's a lot of sample paths so we end
up using a like a a Markov chain Monte
Carlo so all this without assuming in a
statistical model that's one broad
approach and then among the bot
model-based approaches where we assume
some stochastic graph model for the
whole population I would say the one
that's proven most successful has been
the the the bays predictive estimates
that the computational base estimates
using MC MC again with a data
augmentation step in there which imputes
the larger network each iteration so we
get maybe a fourth techno in the process
of making our estimate we get maybe
4,000 estimates of the entire network
and where there's a link where there
isn't what the values are uh yes mm-hmm
yeah it does because I'm regime what was
the design based ones I mean there might
be up there with the design based ones
the key is there has to be a good design
with the model based one there actually
there should be a good design there's a
little there's more leeway a lot of
flexibility on the site it's much easier
to do if the design is ignoring in the
likelihood census as people like Ruben
would say it's easier to do but it has
been done
without that to it but but definitely
yes the and also with the model based
methods it doesn't just depend on the
network properties but again with a good
design with a good sampling design the
model based method works better it's so
so there's there's a lot there and and
so that's just to infer network
properties what I really want to talk
about today is now using the same type
of designs to go in and make to get into
the population into the areas we care
about to make interventions to try to
change not just the units we reach but
the whole population in a favorable way
bring down the HIV epidemic for example
in you know some part of the world or
worldwide so so so so that's that's the
issue and um so um so I'll give it you
know that the last talk i gave it was
called dynamic network type letters to
describe that stuff but they told me I
couldn't you could I couldn't run any
animations or you couldn't show couldn't
run the the program that actually
simulates and shows how we do it and so
and so having just get given a static
talk on dynamic network sampling I'm
going to do the opposite today and not
emphasize put minimal type of my slides
of high camp and see if I can run you're
just a kind of a sample sketch example
of the way I draw these things as I go
but but the ideas you know the
population of intersite so I modeled the
social network based on a social space
an underlying social space structure
seems to be a convenient and meaningful
way and and then use these designs for
sampling the units now the network is
dynamic you know with these park with
these populations the network was always
conceived as static whether it really
was or not I got into the dynamic
networks because when I would visit
people studying these pop
the field actually that network
components the links everything else
would change people would come and go
they move in and out of the population
they died during the courses i do
someone will be sent to jail and it
would change everything so trying to
take that into account and so so what we
and so the basic things we're working
with now are we've got a stochastic
process of Albany all the variables we
kind of making up the network and such
of interest at time T and also we have a
sampling process the nodes you know say
the set of nodes in our sample at time
pls changing and um and so when we want
to remember for you know these models
can get complex right then there's also
somebody says you know you've got to
include this other variable with you
know these people and and but the
perspective here is we want a base model
that tells us is one design better than
another there's one sampling designer
one intervention strategy better than
another the kite and so we want to
include the kind of things that affect
that we'd like it to be as simple as
possible but include things like
clustering mixing you know between
groups um a migration of a person from
one social group to another you know all
that with a spatial point process you
know movement kind of movements in
social space some person moves closer
further from someone else and the whole
even the group there in can move you
know kind of drift around like that and
also the nodes themselves are transient
you know people come into the study you
know they they if they're not your
source we've got a birth and death
process here they they move away they
die if they come in not literally by
birth but may become univ age where
they're there of it you know they grow
up and they're in the high-risk group
now or they move from a another area so
we build on a spatial
temporal point process we have linked
probabilities depending on distances
between nodes also characteristics of
the origin node the destination node
and/or and the combination of the two so
the link itself and no waves of wavelet
so links are constantly being inserted
and deleted formed and dissolving and so
so in in the static situation
classically a sampling design means the
selection that the procedure for
selecting a unit into the sample and um
but here we have here we have actually
an acquisition process by which units
are added in the sample and an attrition
process by which units leave the sample
they'll leave the sample if you know if
I mean if it's a study sample bill you
know they people won't be tired of being
in your study bill move from there
people will die during the city and so
on and we we'd like it to come into some
kind of a balance between the two and
we'll look at natural designs that have
these processes to and then it's a
little surprising since all the things
were used to talking about in here about
networks and their properties and you
know limiting district and amok through
a network and what are the limiting
probability you know what it goes
forever right then and it has limiting
probabilities that are the four
different nodes that are the elements of
the eigenvectors and stuff like that but
now our nodes themselves are transient
but we still have will still see some
stationary you know summer got occurs or
and stationary limiting distributions
include
from our sample so let me um yeah so so
so entrance is the first thing I talked
about experiments we how do we select a
sample in order to do a field experiment
interventions are related because with
the experiment will make an intervention
on a unit but there we would like the
risk response on one unit to be
unaffected by interventions on other
goods here we'd like to make our
interventions on the smallest number of
units and affect the biggest number
right we want to affect our whole
population so let me um let me just
pause so I don't run out of time and
just look at an example of if if we can
hear of
so this is how we're modeling these
things here here's three hundred nodes
the the basic time step is a day because
the idea is that people are making
seemingly trivial day-to-day choices and
this is what has the big effect on the
population i'll talk about larger sample
sizes ripper this is like 300 and and
will go up to some tens of thousands if
we want or or i'll talk about larger
sample sizes but we're looking at so
here i have kind of an explosive rise of
an epidemic this is the HIV epidemic now
the virus that the HIV virus it's
selecting a sample a sample of people by
much the same design as this a person is
selected when they're in fact this
person is selected with very low
probability per contact this is modeling
the heterosexual you know sexual
transmission of HIV through a
subpopulation a very low probability
through / context also it's surprising
how like you know 33 million people in
the world infected runs on with these
seemingly small probabilities but
there's some clever things the virus
does and then then this person is
infected and with different
probabilities it might you know trace
some of these links might completely not
transmit on some and so on and and so we
see and so here's the kind of pattern so
this is ample time step it's moving as a
day this is showing the degree
distribution that's always changing of
course because all these things are
stochastic but this is one of the things
that has the state as stationary
distribution in our gotik distribution
you know this is just a random run I
don't know what it's going to do but I
know that if I run it again this goes
for 400 years day by day I know if I ran
it again I'll get exactly the same with
the same rate values to send parameter
values
I'll get exactly the same stationary
distribution as a as a stochastic
process ends and so so so so this is
like showing that you know we've got
like maybe if 40 some percent this is
like a high-risk situation right a
40-percent a rise to a 40-percent
infection rate because the basic degree
is you know an average degree of two and
then these high ones in the tail this is
a high-risk population you know so
there's lots of different settings this
can spread through so 400 years so we're
looking at what we're at about a hundred
years now right so so so 146,000 days
deficit in Cedars there's a lot of
computation so we want things to be
simple and and here's our infected notes
now liked let's look at some other views
if we can um so here's our this is just
one run of this process there's and so
there's there's a there's a spatial
point process that positions the nodes
yo ends and so now imagine we go to the
next day every node just kind of Wiggles
and drifts a little bit a function of
distance that that goes like this and
not only that but there's two people
that form a link they you use the word
consensus I think or something yeah it's
a consensus design for forming the link
but for dissolving the link it's like
one person or the other can decide to
dissolve it I mean that sort of
realistic but sort of oversimplified to
it that can be modified to have one
person a little more dominant in those
choices that but that's the idea so
there's actually you know the other
person has a link like this too and it's
like you might say the product of those
who and then the square root of that
I I started out using logistic function
for these things but now i'm using a
half normal because when i do the
product and the square root it's like it
averages the reciprocal of the spreads
of the through different but so so so so
so it's a distance model like that
there's a drift it's got groupings like
you we can look at them if we want um
yeah yeah when you see something great
that's a node I'm dying or moving out of
it now HIV goes in stages and people
have a higher a higher rate of mortality
when they're infected that has a big
effect on the dynamics of this thing and
then the antiretrovirals increase you
increase the survival time decrease the
mortality but not not quite to natural
don't recruit to natural mortality and
um yeah so let's look at some other
things in here here there's the Centers
of the architects here's the center of
their group of it this is a this is a
drift around process itself it's
stationary but it stays uniform but it's
always drifting on kind of keeping its
momentum and stuff but let me so that's
just on the construction
and so this is the whole population here
buddy model here's just the sample the
virus has selected this sample and so so
these are the infected nodes and and I'm
showing in dark those are the the
surface of the sample the surface of the
sub graph that's in fact social so those
are the links those are the ones to
watch out for because and you notice
sometimes they're thicker than others
those are the people in early-stage HIV
which is you know like several too many
times higher transmission rate than you
know for the first few weeks and so
those are particularly risky so it's a
surface that we you know in a way that
we want to cut down on in in some way or
rather so there's some some interesting
geometry over time here here's another
way of well let me go to something else
instead that here's the components
that's another thing that's all it's
changing right revd is the largest
component blue the next largest green
the next largest but you see it changes
like here's one great big component but
I'm see this one broke off from it now
and so I saw the dynamics are always
changing and and and here's some and and
here's one more thing H so the whole
reason HIV is hard to control and
everything doesn't quite work does it
mutates so fast so an RN I arrives
mutate so fast so here I'm having it
mutates specifically that early
transmission rate when what we find it
does is it adapts to the network
geometry I with a rate just uniform from
zero to really large for the early stage
and so we started out with a
a high on a very spread but high average
early transmission rate over time it
comes to an equally but here's one more
of these ergodic equilibrium
distributions it comes down to a
favorable way because there's a
trade-off if it's too virulent it
increases the person's mortality its
hosts that it depends on dies off
changes the dynamic that that's what the
whole thing depends on and so here's a
distribution of it and that that these
are the low rates and when it starts out
you would see there's a medium rate you
would see red for high rates and stuff
but and and there's one and there's just
one more way I'll show that it's really
useful to look at these network samples
in time so let me let me go to where
we're just looking at a sample if I 10
and see if that so here here we're
looking at longitudinally at the sample
and so each node is and you're watching
you'll see kind of well it's to let me
even start that over if I can't all just
push on one more button and stop there I
think
oh here it is notice the explosive the
explosive spread this is a little
speeded up at the explosions where
you'll say go along like this for a long
race and then poof that's from that
early transmission rate that's a key
thing it evolves to take advantage you
know to to get away from zero and get up
towards its towards its equilibrium
value and a strain of HIV that can do
that has it has an advantage over
surrounding strange that can't do that
and so they become predominant yeah so
that's I used up my time so that yeah I
guess we now have a break until three
thirty and then we'll we'll meet again
for Marcus's talkin and a discussion